By the way we've got some serious Grobanites
in the VFF wall.
And in our second segment we'd like to play a game called,
Random Fandom, where we see which one can get picked
to give a little Grobanite love to Mr. Groban himself.
I think that's a really fun idea.
Let's do it.
Okay, good,
I'm glad you're game for it.
Happy belated 40th birthday, by the way.
Thank you very much, thank you.
How does it feel?
Yeah, weird to have
a birthday in the middle of all of this.
My balloons, I sat on my floor.
I had a virtual party,
I was able to see some friends and band and crew,
but all on Zoom.
You have the same birthday as your brother
but you're four years apart, right?
That's right.
Yeah, I was fully expecting like a cowboy clown party
on my fourth birthday, I had it all set up,
my friends were coming over, I had ice cream cake
and my dad's like, "Nope, we're going in the car.
We're going to the hospital
and you got a different present instead."
So yeah, having a baby brother
on my birthday was a weird thing.
We're like best friends now.
Did you ever ask your parents why this time of year,
nine months ago seemed to be such a festive one
in their lives?
(audience laughing)
(Josh laughing)
I think, I don't wanna just be totally weird about it
but I think it's like my mom's birthday.
Right.
You know?
So I don't know, my parents had been together
50 years so I would imagine it's more than just birthdays,
but, who knows?
[Drew laughing]
Your show is like, it's Prozac.
It makes me so happy, but I mean, medically don't,
it's like, I can't prescribe a TV show to people
but it makes me so happy to watch your show.
Your energy is so infectious
and I'm not a morning person generally, but just being awake
and talking to you, it's just like, my day's gonna be great.
You know, when we did the show and we started,
we were all learning a new normal.
And when you talked about how the transition
was when you would perform virtually
and you weren't able to hear any response whatsoever,
I picture crickets on tumbleweeds
like riding through the Wild West.
How was that for you?
'Cause that's how we started out too.
Yeah, as you know so well, I mean,
having that bounce back and forth
with an audience to kind of tell you how the energy's going
and where you wanna drift right and left
and my whole entire life
since I was 17 years old was being put in front
of an audience and kind of walking that tight rope walk.
And so, being put in front of a camera
and saying, okay, you got 90 minutes to do a show.
And there's no worst nightmare
for a singer than finishing like a really big note
and just hearing nothing afterwards, just absolute crickets.
You have to like, imagine that these thousands
of people around,
the world are clapping in their living rooms
and there was something poetic about it.
I'm in a little box in Burbank and I'm singing to,
God knows who's out there.
And we're all in these little boxes around the world
and you find out later, I'm sure you do too,
you find out on social media and stuff
how much people enjoyed the show and what it meant to them.
And you realize how many people
tuned in from countries that I'd never been to
in my entire life.
And you think about the access of being able to do a show
for people that I might not have been able to tour
for if it was in person.
So you realize that there's actually some magic to it.
I can't wait to get to a live audience,
but you make the most of it.
Another thing that I loved is that you like
to hit a baseball stadium in almost every city
that you tour, is this true?
Yeah, so when I get to tour during the summer,
truly there is no greater and more fun thing
than just doing a bunch of outdoor venues
when you're touring over the summer.
And when you have a day off, like, I'm a big baseball fan.
I grew up in LA, so I'm Dodger blue, but I love-
No Angels?
I love
baseball.
Rivals, but lots of respect, amazing team.
I mean, some of the best players in the country,
but, no, see I feel like with baseball rivalry,
I feel like you have to be a fan of the team
like your dad took you to as like a kid,
you have to be a part of the team that like,
you saw when you were little and got the foam finger
and had the hot dog,
like that's what's in your veins for your whole life.
And I'm in New York a lot of the time
and I'll go see the Yankee games and stuff.
But when I'm touring in a town
and there's a baseball game going on,
I don't care who's playing,
I just like going to the stadium.
I like kind of feeling the vibe of it and I miss that.
I mean, we know we all miss that a lot.
Well, I got excited again I related to you
because I hit a museum in every city that I tour.
And so I was like, I know, and when you're working,
you kind of go in, you land, you run to the hotel,
you do the show and you leave the next morning.
And when you're on a press tour or a music tour
I'm sure the schedule is somewhat similar.
And so you're trying desperately to make the most
of your time there.
And you kind of get to do one extracurricular thing
if you can squeeze it in there.
And so I love that you did that
'cause I know I understand that lifestyle.
And I'm really excited about your new album
which is Harmony Deluxe.
It's a collection of songs that I've loved for a very,
very long time.
As a singer, you get kind of a bucket list of songs
you've wanted to interpret
and wanted to sing for a long time,
fans request for a very, very long time.
And then there were a couple of originals too,
that came from just being at home
and at a piano for this last year.
This is the first time I've ever had to record
an album where almost everything was virtual, where I'm here
and the orchestra's in London
and the producer's in Nashville.
And, it's again very detached,
but at the same time for all of us to have
the energy to make it all come together.
And it's kind of why we called the album Harmony.
It was really a difficult,
but inspiring process to get it all coming
out of the speakers the way we wanted.
Well, I really like how you got so inventive
in this last year and I am not an idle person
nor can I ever be.
And the fact that you were getting back on GarageBand
and just reaching out to people and going, okay,
I've got this to this point in the song,
who else can I join to take it to the end
and the collaboration and the innovative innovation,
I just thought was super cool.
It's fun when you can utilize those tools for good things.
There's so much time, we waste time
with the technology over the years.
And this has been a time where I think everybody
has tried to take the time
by themselves to learn a new skill
to brush up on production skills
or cooking or co-writing or whatever it is.
And so in this otherwise very traumatic year
I'm gonna take the silver linings of the things
that I kind of try to get better at.
(upbeat music)